>> So,
the service worker think is pretty good.
I mean, it's really good.
But all it is a simple JavaScript
file that sits between you and
network requests.
It's a type of web worker.
Meaning, it runs
separately from your page.
It isn't visible to the user.
It can't access the DOM, but
it does control pages and by control.
I mean, intercepts requests
as the browser makes them.
>From there, you can do, well,
whatever you want really.
You can send the request off to
the network, as per usual or
you can skip the network.
Go to some kind of cache or
create a custom random response, or
any combination of those things.
You register for
a service worker like this,
giving the location of your
service work a script.
It returns a promise.
So, you get call backs for
success and failure.
If you're unfamiliar with promises,
don't worry.
We'll guide you through the bits you
need to know throughout the course.
If you call register when the service
work is already registered, that's fine.
The browser won't re-register it.
It'll just return a promise for
the existing registration.
You can also provide a scope.
The service worker will control any
page whose URL begins with the scope and
it will ignore any that don't.
So for this example, the service worker
will control a page at this URL and
also anything with a deeper URL, but
not anything with a shallower URL.
The service worker doesn't
get to control this one, nor
will it control an unrelated URL.
But be aware that this service
worker won't control this URL,
as it doesn't have the trailing slash.
So it counts, as a shallower URL.
You can have multiple service
workers with different scopes,
which is really handy for
something like GitHub pages when
multiple projects share the same origin.
Scopes let you have a different
service worker for each project.
The default scope is determined by the
location of the service worker script.
It's basically the path
that script sits in.
Usually, you don't
need to set the scope.
Just put the service worker
script in the right place, but
what happens within the service worker?
Well, you listen for particular events.
Just like other JavaScript events,
you can react to them or
even prevent the default and
do your own thing.
We'll introduce these events one
by one as the cost progresses,
but what about browser support?
This site is service worker ready has
a breakdown of support by features.
There's a link to that
in the presenter notes.
Every browser has expressed
some interest in implementing.
But as of 2015, service worker
is only support it in Chrome and
Opera with Firefox support soon to land.
But just because a technology
isn't universally supported,
it doesn't mean you should wait.
The service worker is entirely
progressive enhancement friendly.
Meaning, we can use it in browsers that
support it without disrupting users of
older browsers.
They just won't get the benefits.
In fact, using the stuff today to
improve the user experience will
encourage of a browser to implement it.
So, their users get the benefit too.
To use service worker in a safe
progressive enhancing way,
just make sure you write code
in a simple feature detect.
If a browser doesn't
support service workers,
navigator.serviceWorker will be
undefined, which is a faulty value.
So, older browsers will skip
everything within the if statements and
avoid trying to call functions
that aren't defined.
That's most of the nitty-gritty
details covered.
So let's all hold hands chance and
summon our Resident Quizmaster,
Mike Wales.
Mike, can you hear me
from beyond the Atlantic?
>> I certainly can.
It's time to get quizzical.